a movie starring Sir Anthony Hopkins how
can this go wrong keep in mind he is
still the guy from free Jack the right
the right is the story of this young guy
who's about to become an ordained priest
he kind of had shaky faith to begin with
so he thought okay I'm gonna go into
seminary school then if I'm not feeling
it after four years right before I get
ordained just drop out it's just pretty
much the point he's ended up at so his
main priest teacher is like okay you
have shaky faith all right go to the
Vatican learn to become an exorcist I
guess you thought all right you'll
either be scared straight or I'm
throwing a defenseless lamb to the
slaughter and you'll just die this man
guy I've never seen this guy before in
my entire life I have no idea where they
found it probably the same arcade they
found Eddie furlong he kind of looks
like Peter Petrelli and Jake
Gyllenhaal's love child and for my money
they have made the most relatable
character in recent cinema and I'll tell
you why because for the first hour and a
half in this movie this guy's just like
I hate this I don't even want to see
this right now this is stupid I want to
go home and for the first hour and a
half in this movie you're also like I
hate this I don't even want to see this
right now this is stupid I want to go
home and there you go relatable for me
this is my problem with the guy he's
just so blah all the time he has no
personality he's just what I call blah
he's like selma Blair on Downer's he's
just like father we need some answers
man I know you have a crisis of faith
going on right now but how about this
make a command decision either become a
Christian or an atheist whatever you do
get a little bit of personality no side
will hate you for that
and Anthony Hopkins is in it and the
guy's a good actor he plays the role
really well he's this unorthodox
Exorcist priests mentor tight but even
though he played his character well his
character was still he came across as
like he just doesn't give a he's
just like right yeah yeah you're blessed
okay whatever I peace out all right
we'll see you next Tuesday because this
exorcism isn't done cuz that's how they
roll I mean between Keanu 2.0 and father
oh I don't give a you just don't
give a the movies two hours long
and in the last 20 minutes of the movie
it finally picks up and you get to see
all the cool exorcism that you came
to see you can YouTube any exorcism you
don't have to sit through the hour and a
half of to get there so Anthony
Hopkins good actor main character no
idea I don't know who he is so busy can
you tell me but the movie itself boring
it was just really boring so in that I'm
not even gonna be nice about it
or what's the difference
not sure but I like so this
movie is not gonna lie not a
solid week for you guys however on my
channel you have nearly 200 videos that
make for hours upon hours of
entertainment shameless self promoting
yeah but I do it I can but if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
right after this picture of Aaron who
recognized me in Seattle that was really
cool that was badass
[Music]